wie war es für dich wenn du jetzt wieder
schwanger war also wieder werden in
gröst als war dass wenn ich kein vater
wehrte gleich show gemacht aber ich weiß
wie empfindlich menschen wo sich aus
unterschiedlichen gründen bewusst dazu
entscheidet kein hinzu einfach nur dass
die kinder kriegen das kinderkriegen
willens das finde ich einfach für das
kind nicht gut für die umwelt auch mit
unbedingt besser und das fällt halt
keine lücke
und dann wandern das durchbringen
und anregen die entwerten
ja schon immer ein großer fan der wunsch
kam im umfeld vor zu langsamer das mini
kolleginnen und kollegen hinderte mich
dass da zum beispiel sbb vom inneren
freunde in der chemie gleichzeitig kann
ich aber diskussionen mit liegt wo man
sagt das ist aufgrund von der umwelt
nicht könntet verantwortlich hinterwald
setzte jetzt frage ich mich bin ich
egoistisch wenn ich mittags noch immer
wünsche
ich wird unser finde was menschen dazu
bringt sich tages entscheiden
ich mache ein reporter menschen sich
bewusst entscheiden ins büro
oder endlich einmal so gedanken gemacht
oder ist das einfach schon immer klar
sie
für die sich eigentlich immer klar zu
sandwiches und der wunsch nicht zum
glück in erfüllung gegangen wie es mir
gedanken gemacht wenn es die rechtlich
wird kappe
und in ihm drin ist weiß auch der frau
die meisten handys oder hemd
kinderwunsch und jetzt dieses thema zu
dem ich ganz im babyglück trotzdem ist
es nicht immer nur einfach ich meine
hände
noch alles gut aber es ist
mit
[Musik]
24 stunden job
in hamburg
weil sie sich so absolut nachsitzen
stock und dank so wir haben ja bitte
kreis hinderlich gegen wurde da finde
ich sehr mega bewusst da wir werden die
wagen klima paket wartet aber das musste
ich so gedanken machen aber weiß ja dass
irgendwie den deutschen gerichten im
flieger oder ich mache irgendwie dumm
ist einfach meine art ist klimaschutz
sehen wir ganz besonders das ja was wenn
das heißt what car ist natürlich auch
etwas allgemein
gewalt was auch jetzt groß und weiter
ich mein kind nicht
ich meine ich danke den süden ziehen ich
lieber wie
generation
wissen ist was bleibt mir ja absolut
ich mal wieder zurück von der jamie ist
natürlich megahertz ich sie also doch
lieber süß und ich aus vielen monatlich
zurück gespielt weil ich den kopf hin
und weg so denkt aber wie kann man so
etwas nicht welle
logisches der hofstelle aber glaube es
geht am mega viel zurück
da sind zum beispiel wichtige gedanken
gemacht hat sie überhaupt als welt
sondern ist klar ich glaube ich dass
auch jüngere babbel trainer da die
diskussionen kann mit anderen und darum
jetzt hat gewundert was mir dann die
andere seite wo sich bewusst zu
entscheiden
ich fahre fuhr und dafür mit sydney sie
hat sich auf den aufruf gemeldet wo ich
gut gesucht haben muss ich auf grund von
klima gewinnt entscheidet auf der ufra
fendt sich einige frauen untereinander
gemeldet ich habe mich entschieden weil
sie mit 24 schon sehr bestimmt die
haltung zu dem thema hat ich stehe für
mich mit ihr zum zmittag
und sagen dazu
bewusst die entscheidung trifft straße
verhindert das hat mehrere gründe also
ja es billig macht zu verfahren betreut
und den
ersten mega spaß gemacht oder im hits
mit kläger also respekt an ich mehr
tatenlos zu finden so
streng zum kind und einfach mit dem
ganze klima waren dann kann auch wenn
ich meine wenn die familie wars gibt
zukunft sehr genau es sind oft welt
setzte die maschine auch überleben wird
und
wo sie dann wird es schlimmer wird
[Musik]
zielsetzung sei für die sie stahl von
der nachhaltigkeit kommission nach
kurzem begann und sogar ab und zu
wirklich leid sagen
ja wenn ich mir vorstelle dass
wahrscheinlich noch oft
wenn du dich österreich zu nehmen oder
die man ja
noch so jung oder wasser waten und ist
richtig mache und wenn er sich
entscheidet wo weg
mehrere andere person
wenn jetzt so
wird wohl ein kinderwunsch
wie willst du denn der geht
ja dann wäre es klappt mega schwierig
aber ich denke mal
die welle bezweckt den beenden wieso das
jedoch selber
noch ein baby war glücklich mache
aber dennoch nicht auf die
angeschlossenen sowie tun das hat die
person seit jahren entweder
etwas anderes wenn man die witzig also
ich könnte noch mit demonstrativer sich
nachhaltig tickt wie ich bin also es ist
mir egal wichtig und ich sogar zum
beispiel das auch nicht flüge in europa
mit vegetarischer aber habe ich schon
immer dahin der wunsch und ich hoffe ich
also ich frage mich wie man sich das
egoistische studios egoistischer
überhaupt nicht als mega schlimmer als
die trau dir berufszweig bewegung
katrina ist unverantwortbar und wenn ja
niemand mehr hinter also nicht
ausdrücklich denn wäre die 100 jahr wäre
einfach ausgestorben hat vor allem sich
mal für europa hätten ja ok
[Musik]
bevölkert lösung von problemen und
egoistisch als war sie aber egoistisch
finden wenn ich will man partner das hat
die höher gebildeten und eine
psychiaterin weder
sowie lokale erledigung europaministerin
interessieren ich habe das gefühl es im
geburtsstätte schnitt lösung für sein
problem diese generation new york also
ich sags mal generation gerät denn wer
jetzt das umweltthema hier so präsent
wie die musiker was ich mir vorstelle
[Musik]
so fleck mutterschaft oder wird jemals
reduzieren oder gehalt der in rostock
dabei etwas wird nicht schön oder die
ganze klimaflüchtlinge und so schickte
mir so engagiere ich bewundere wie
konsequent sie aber trotzdem nicht
gestorben sagt es hat sich alles andere
wenn man einmal in ihrer beziehung mit
gott hast du dir denn eigentlich wenn
sie sich so klar ist schon mal gedanken
darüber gemacht ich zu unterbinden so
unterbindet also ich glaube dass man
eben weil sie so gemacht aber ich habe
irgendwann die eltern also weiter ins
kühle den runden im neuen schub oder
vielleicht mache ich
sowieso
ein wichtiger zeitpunkt kein porsche
mehr inhaber also meine haben jetzt ja
auf andere bis jetzt und jetzt dass sie
die werkstatt 15 jahren auf ein riff und
man ist einfach unser ding gelaufen ist
aber noch endgültig
fast eine sekunde wird aus dem tritt und
gutscheine bürgers dass er das thema
erledigt wäre wie war's dann für die
hände zur schwang erwarte
ja
denn was wir machen auftrieb
zuerst kühl klar ab blieb aber ich denke
auch in der situation entscheide ich
natürlich noch mal anders also meine
studenten
warfen die antriebs ist groß
und es
hat
ich habe alle user finde wie verliebte
die schweiz bewusst kinderlos sind
weiter geht's der türkei knabe zahlen
welt statistik nicht zwischen gewollte
und ungewollte kinderlosigkeit
unterscheidet was man sieht ist das
geburtenrate der schweiz die letzte jahr
abgeholt
ich bin büren kanton nidwalden auch
absurd wäre unter alex nicht bewusst
dazu entschieden ins büro und das auf
grund für den lifestyle würde ich mal
sagen es gibt verschiedene gründe
weder und alex sind sie zu aktie
bedeutet für sie ist es sehr klar dass
sie keinen wind es hat sich einfach
ergeben weil wir genießen ehrlich gesagt
das leben schon sehr und wir reisen
extrem gern war es jetzt auch im
september georgen im kaukasus unterwegs
sondern sind vorbei an weggerannt und
solches hat sondern das ist dann halt
irgendwie weg für mindestens 18 jahre
oder das 30 einfach mehr diese freiheit
und die flexibilität ich im leben habe
dass ich sagen kann ich habe keine lust
darauf eingestellt sein ich könnte jetzt
eine firma und schau mal wie es läuft
und muss mir nur um mich selbst sorgen
machen am ende des tages oder wir haben
halt auch viele beispiele in der familie
und im freundeskreis wo wir dann einfach
das miterlebt haben und dann einfach
gesehen ja wollen wir da wollen wir das
nicht und werde ich bei meiner familie
und so kam das wohl eher so dass ich
dazu gedrängt wurde und seitdem ich halt
mit wem zusammen bin mag ich das einfach
so ja ich glaube auch von der wenn man
jetzt weltweit die demografie einfach
betrachtet haben wir auch denke ich eine
mehr wert wenn wir nicht nach einem
weiteren konsumenten haben so
auszudrücken
[Musik]
schließlich haben wir auch ein baby
720 geschützte also dass die eine
diverse augen fall an rucksäcken
[Musik]
meiner erfahrung einfach beobachtern als
wenn man ein kind hat dann dann gibt man
sein leben schon so ein bisschen auf für
die zeit und dann ist das halt einfach
du bist jetzt mutti oder du bist jetzt
partie und du bist jetzt familie und
dann kannst du nicht aber sagen du lass
uns mal nach kurdistan fahren weil es
lustig ist aber im gleitschirmfliegen
oder sowas und das ist halt abenteuer
man kann ich das ego ist muss bezeichnen
die politik würde ich als egoistisch
bezeichnen bei der nächste steuerzahler
kommt nicht auf die welt aber ich sehe
ist halt er einfach nur
die leben unser leben und genießen es
wie die anderen auch einfach nur ohne
kinder ja ich hatte nie das bedürfnis 0
0 es ist einfach nicht da es ist so wie
ich habe das bedürfnis wandern zu gehen
zum beispiel
[Gelächter]
wo man
entweder unter alex center damals und
name und bot für camper umbaut und
abonniert er reißt sich nicht mit kind
kreise oder dass ich es zwar hier denken
man muss man muss sagen im auto macht
das schon sind zu reisen mit kindern
aber wenn du fernreisen mit dem flugzeug
davids und sofort auf also wenn gerade
in die länder wo wir hinwollen da ist
das mit kindern ist es eigentlich und
verantwortungsvoll
vor zwei jahren sind wir und der alex
für deutschland die schweiz zog das
unter anderem autos gebiete werke sind
und jederzeit in ein neues abenteuer
staaten
durch nun hier verleiht wieder sehr
schwächliche reise lifestyle nimmt
mehrere helfer finden scheint vermessen
dass ihr kind wenn ich die leute sehen
wie sie jetzt heutzutage arbeiten oder
die sind dann einfach nicht mehr fit im
alter weil du kriegst du die ganze zeit
ich sagen modernen krankheiten
bluthochdruck diabetes durch schlechte
ernährung durch zu viel stress zum
alltag und das ziel ist eigentlich im
alter so fit zu sein dass du wirklich
dann wird ein camper durch die gegend
fahren kannst oder dann haben wir
vielleicht häuslingen georgien und haben
ein bescheidenes leben und natürlich
braucht vielleicht irgendwann jemand der
dich pflegt aber seien wir mal ehrlich
welche kinder wo gibt es auch drei
generationen haushalte wo die kinder und
enkelkinder ihre großeltern pflegen
daher sehe ich das für mich eher wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir finanziell
so gut aufgestellt sind dass wir uns
leisten können dass sich jemand um uns
kümmert wenn man muss halt auch einfach
das potenzial global sehen von der
menschheit weil es gibt genug menschen
auf dem planeten irgendwann wird halt
jemand der nicht mein kind das auch für
mich arbeiten können einfach weiter
nebenplatz hat hier zu leben oder hier
leben möchte
immer wieder bücher mit die beide
kommentars kühle für bekannte
wochentrend und dann kommt immer dass
man den anderen ja oh ist das schön wenn
man keine kinder hat man kann dann
machen was man will ja soll ich dir
zeigen willst es ist solche soll ich
aufpassen oder so wie sie dieses gefühl
noch mal heute haben
denk mir schon so ok wieso hast du sagen
kannst du das beneiden du hast ja
eigentlich die größte glück du dich
selbst gefunden und da solltest du
eigentlich jemanden der das nicht hat
oder ein anderes glück hat nicht hinein
aber das bedeutet ja dass hier
eigentlich unbewusst gehandelt haben sie
haben sich gar nicht sie waren sich gar
nicht im vornherein im kleinen wie sich
das leben theoretisch verändert was mein
wunsch einfach wäre dass die leute das
bewusst sich dafür entscheiden einfach
nur dass die kinder kriegen des
kinderkriegen willens das finde ich
einfach für das kind nicht gut für die
umwelt auch nicht unbedingt besser und
ich glaube auch die person selbst das
feld keine lücke wenn die leute vorher
einfach da aber ich hatte weder und alex
schäfer stehe für sie und ihre schlappe
ist es denn wohl besser kreis ins haus
aber ich freue mich trotzdem wie das der
in zukunft mit ihrer altersvorsorge und
der pflege im auto
wie ist es für dich nun auch sie wurden
zusammen sind ich jetzt lieber der dax
fiel büro das velo voll und feiere ich
und du mit dem nicht so ist zu lesen
es war schon genau das war schon so dass
am anfang war das eigentlich sie haben
uns kennengelernt und
[Musik]
ja soll ich sagen also weiß ich so oder
doch muss ich jetzt ehrlich sein jan ist
war schon so dass der kinderwunsch von
meiner seite da war muss man schon sagen
aber es
war für mich nicht der beziehungs
abhängig dass ich mit diesen menschen
dann nicht zusammenleben will wenn er
kein kind haben möchte oder sowas
deswegen bin ich da bin halt ziemlich
neutral demgegenüber gewissen gewesen
die große frage kind ja oder nein als
protagonistin hat dazu eine klare
haltung so sander ist journalistin dj
und lieder schaffte feministin
für sie ist klar sie wird greifen
trotzdem geht es aber das credo ein
große rolle in ihrem leben spielt ihres
gottes rosa die beiden verbringen viel
zeit mit genannt rosander bringt sie
heute ist fußball trennen
ist interessanter für
die technischen themen wie berichtet
das ist aber schön was ist das coolste
oder was machen wir doch mal zusammen
den film avatar
und
rocknet all diese hammer weißt du
eigentlich dass großen teich hinweg ich
wünsche das
gut
dann bin ich ja
mein
anspruch nur 50 und damit war das
punktespringen der hai und dann könnte
die elbeflut noch jemand spaßiges auch
schön aber
hey wenn sie dann nehmen
sie natürlich dorf
und aber auch immer noch finden
das wiso watt und schweiz vor allem auf
850 landes also findet frau hat man das
auch im nachteil weil nach hintergrund
vor dem karriereknick
gesellschaftliche anliegen nicht
vorhanden ist
wenn man mehr hat also wenn ich keinen
vater werde ich schon gemacht
beste
qualität und
informiert auch in der hand und das sage
nein ich also das wie alles andere als
treffpunkt
ich glaube dass neue schlacht bei der
geeignet machen wir
nachher sehr gut mit sie hat mir aber
offiziell dass sie dank dass sie das nur
so gut dran weil es eine delegierte sind
ich habe irgendwie also ich komme gern
kind das ist nett aber ich bin ich
wirklich forschung der minister gründen
also ich
finde irgendwie dass das dass man
wenigstens als frau in der schweiz sich
noch andere hobbys vormachen dass man
sich prächtig wie es nach innen hat und
dann kontert und es macht mich zu hassen
oder und das gefühl wenn ich jetzt noch
im bett wird dass das irgendwie amecker
verschärfen also ist das irgendwie als
auch im sport vor dem aktivismus ducati
ich habe schon einiges zeit ich glaube
die bestimmung ist enel beschrieben oder
fans machen oder so in die spur
als kind gebären ich mein management aus
rheinstetten entstehen demonstriert man
wahrscheinlich nimmt und schreibt bücher
das setzt den vorstoss ins falsche
zeichen weil man den senioren
meniskus ist es denn
nicht das finde ich auch für mich also
die mutter vor der tür
standen und ich finde ich genauso eine
feministische höchstleistung wie mir der
minister bürger über wahrscheinlich die
größer und ich glaube so die idee
den frühen hat vorher schwur klappt also
die erste frau zusammen ist und von dem
mann ist das natürlich für ihn irgendwie
vorrangiges thema xxi sie war ist jetzt
wenn er
jo sogar kind
also
erstens kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
dass das passiert ja es wäre also
also ich war fix mit absagen los angeles
person mit einer zusammen beschwingt
gegeben hat dass das so dass ich mir
über live
also macht und dass ich dann doch die
vorentscheidung dann hast du
vielleicht eher egoistisch wenn du ich
möchte
ich meine dass ich dann blöd oder
sind ihre spieler
peinlich
tschuldigung ich nur
am
[Musik]
sonntag sieht schwarz wenn es um
vereinbarkeit von beruf und familie
lieber gott ich sehr problem schaffen
dass es viel mehr es geht wurde job und
kind und ein hut bringt drum hand
hoffnung noch nicht verloren
ich stell mir das einfach stimmen die
zukunft sofort abstellen
und ich habe das gefühl
ganz ehrlich nicht in bezug auf sehr
gute nicht in clubs aber
dann sollten die haare und mitchell
einfach die eckpunkte und da einfach die
werk ist so klatschte die dem land mami
blieb geheim punkt
na ja
also ich
besteht so fest wo seinerzeit und hoffe
so fest dass man das irgendwie anders
mache ich mir gar nicht mehr lang
studiert und ausbildung gemacht für das
dass ich noch ein zwei jahre schaffen
denn wenn es kommen auch 100 einsätze
das habe ich auch nichts und ich hoffe
dass es irgendwie möglich ist das
kombinieren und dadurch natürlich auch
der partner wo vielleicht auch
reduzieren das muss man sich natürlich
auch eine leichte
bio also für konsequente sieht das so
reduziert und das glaube ich sagt axel
wirklich kalt in der wunsch aktivismus
das spiel gut aber was man jetzt über
die ganze reportage einfach nur mal
bewusst wurde ich habe jedem sinne
persönliche entscheidung niemand anderem
triebfeder wind weht oder mit man muss
sich nicht rechtfertigen muss netz
gefühl haben recht egoistisch sondern
dass es wie ein eigener entscheidung für
sich trifft und was ich immer sage ich
einfach
platz am anfang von mineralproben in
ihrer kollegin ich bin natürlich sehen
bewusst dass das baby madagassische wenn
es hebt
geschlafen und sie nachts sind wird
älter das wird anstrengend das bin ich
mir durchaus bewusst
aber für wirtschaft familie mega wichtig
und das ist jetzt mein punkt ist weit
und da geht es mit war sage zu meinen
karin und finden muss das akzeptieren
und er ne frage einige der protagonisten
oder
amerikaner stufige und wenn er keine
taschen frequenz gebäude dann aber nicht
den kanal und wie gesagt ich freue mich
mein leben gekommen